last time we started discussing the
extremal problem for bipartite graphs in
particular we saw the Kaveri shows Turin
Durham which tells us that if you forbid
your graph from having a complete
bipartite graph KST then you have this
upper bound on the number of edges in
your graph so we gave a proof floss
fairly short use the double counting
argument and give you the spam and next
question is how tight is this bound is
there a lower bound that is off by let's
say a most a constant factor and that's
a major open problem there's a
conjecture that this bound is tight up
to constant factors but that conjecture
is known for only a very small number of
graphs and we saw a couple of examples
last time so last time we saw a
construction that shows that for s
equals to 2 this bound is tight so the
extremal number for k22 is on the order
of n to the three-halves
so the state a means I'm hiding constant
factors and our construction used this
polarity graph which is essentially the
point lying incidence graph of a
projective plane and a basic algebraic
or geometric fact if you will that two
lines intersecting at most one point we
also saw we sketched a construction that
showed that for s equals to 3 this bound
is also tight and this construction here
involved using spheres again in some in
the space over a finite field
so both these constructions are in some
sense algebraic geometric and you can
ask is there a way to extend these ideas
to construct other examples of KST free
graphs
worth the right number of edges using
some ingredients from algebraic geometry
and today I want to show you two
different ways of doing that so the
state of the art which I mentioned last
time let me remind you what is known
about constructions that achieve the
right exponent up there so in a series
of two papers by a long collar runny and
supple it is shown that if the constants
T and s are such that he is large enough
compared to s particular P is bigger
than s minus 1 factorial then the
extremal number K s T's is of the water
same water as given in the upper bound
of the Kaveri shows Turin theorem in
particular this this range of parameters
allows you to do
two-two three-three which we already
know how to do but the next case is 4 7
and it is still open how to do 4 6
okay so I want to show you this
construction and they'll tell you
exactly what the graph is I'll give you
an explicit description of this graph
which is KSP free and has lots of edges
and as I mentioned earlier it it's an
algebraic construction so as before we
start with P I prime and we will take n
to be a P raised to the power s and
let's restrict has to be integer at
least two and of course as same as last
time if you have other values of n take
a prime close to the desired value and
then take it from there okay to describe
the construction let me remind you a the
norm map if you have a field extension
in this case specifically I'm looking at
the field extension this F P to the S I
can define a norm map as follows sending
X to be the product of all the
conjugates or the Galois conjugates of X
in this field extension actually
explicitly written out it's just that
expression which I can clean and collect
and write it down like this so I wrote
that the image of the snow map lies in
the base field FP and that is because
one of many reasons why this is the case
instead if you look at so I want to know
this norm at pi and if you look at n of
X raise to power P this leaves the
number leaves this value unchanged and
the base field is the field where it has
invariant under power bi people
so here's the graph which I'll denote
the norm graph with parameters P and s
so the norm graph will have as vertices
just the elements of okay so just the
elements of this dispute extension and
the edges will be the set of all pairs
of vertices not equal of course such
that the norm of their sum equals to 1
so that's the graph this is an explicit
description of what the vertices and
what the edges are so now we need to
verify a couple of things one is that
this graph has the desired number of
edges has loss of edges and two is that
this graph is KST 3 so let's do both of
those things so the first is let's check
that has the right number of edges ok so
that's a relatively easy task what we
need to do is to count for every a how
many choices of B are there in this
field extension such that a plus B has
norm exactly 1 and I claim that that
number okay so here's a basic algebra
fact that the number of elements in this
field extension with norm exactly 1 is
precisely P to the S minus 1 divided by
P to the yes
and this is because really we're looking
in the multiplicative subgroup so the
multiplicative group in this FP to the
yes and it is a cyclic group so there's
a generator the order of the cyclic
group is P to the S minus 1 so you're
asking how many elements when raised to
power would embrace to this power here
ends up at the identity so that's the
answer ok so that's one aspect and so as
a result every vertex it's adjacent to
well how many vertices I just need to
for every given a I need to solve for P
and basically there's many solutions I
have to be just slightly careful because
I don't want loops in my graph so I may
need to subtract one so its adjacent to
at least this number up here minus one
to account for possible loops which is
pretty large P to the S minus one which
in other words is and raised to 1 minus
one over s that many vertices and you
see that this gives you the right number
of edges
so okay so this is a graph with lots of
edges so now what that part wasn't so
hard
the next part it's much trickier which
is we want to check that this graph has
no KS TS it so previously in algebraic
construction we used some geometric
facts such as no two lines intersecting
more than one point to show that there's
no k22 in the polarity graph so there's
going to be something like that here
which of the claim is that this
construction just norm graph is K s
comma s factorial plus 1/3 so it's not
quite the bound I claimed so it's a
little bit weaker but it is in the
spirit of what I'm claiming namely it
therefore T large enough this graph is K
s T 3 so for T a large enough count
constant here was shown s factorial plus
1 and as a result it would follow that
the extremal number for S sub K or so S
sub s factorial plus 1 is at least one
half minus little one the constant I
don't really worry about that much but
it's on the order of n to the 3 minus 1
over s ok everyone with me so we need to
verify this this graph here has no KS t
yes question
yes that should be an S thank you any
more questions so we will show later on
a better result using s minus 1
factorial
but for now I'll show you the slightly
weaker result which is still in the same
spirit yep
well change to a different graph for the
stronger result we will change to a
different graph okay so now let's show
that this graph here is KS t3 and for
that claim we need to invoke an
algebraic fact which let me write down
now so suppose we have a field F any
field will walk with a finite field but
any field is fine and I have a bunch of
elements from the field such that a sub
IJ is different from a sub RJ for all I
not the same as R then the system of
equations
I now write down the system so X minus 1
X 1 minus a 1 1 X 2 minus a 1 Q so on XS
minus a 1 s equals to P 1 that's the
first equation second equation X 1 minus
a 2 1 it almost looks like the usual
system of linear equations but I'm
taking products and so on so last one
being X 1 minus a s 1
x2 minus a s to dot a dot XS - a s s
equals to P sub s the system has at most
s factorial solutions we are the I'm
working inside this field okay so that's
the claim so let me just give you some
intuition for this claim suppose the
right side vector is 0 o 0 then I claim
that this is trivial so what is it
saying
I need to select X 1 to be one of the
aides from the first row and X 2 to be
one of the ACE from the second row and
so on but each column of a is distinct
so that's the hypothesis you have oh the
ace in the first column are distinct so
no two of the axis can okay so X I need
to set one of the excise to be one of
the ACE from the first role but you see
that you cannot set x1 to be a1 1 and x1
to be a s1 at the same time
so the solution just counts permutations
which is exactly as factorial
yeah so this algebraic fact plays a key
role in the proof of the theorem that
the lower bound that we're stating up
there if you look at the paper they gave
a proof of this result it's not a long
proof but it uses some community of
algebra and algebraic geometry and you
know usually in a class if you don't if
the instructor doesn't present the proof
it's for one of several reasons
maybe the proof is too short doesn't
need to be presented maybe it's too long
or too difficult maybe it's not
instructive to the class and the last
reason which is the case serious I don't
actually understand the proof I said I
can follow it line by line but I don't
understand why it is true and if one of
you wants to come up with a different
proof or try to explain to me how this
seemingly elementary algebraic fact is
proved I'd be quite I would appreciate
it now for small values of s you can
check it by hand right so x equals to 2
you're solving a system of you know two
quadratic equations and that you can
check by hand and three maybe you can do
with some work but even with four it's
not so clear how to do it and also one
of the geometric intuition is that if B
is 0 then you have exactly s factorial
solutions and the geometric intuition is
somehow that if you move be around then
the fiber the size of a fiber the number
of solutions X can only go down and
cannot go up and this corresponds to
some algebraic geometry
phenomenon and that's all I will say
about this algebraic fact which will now
use as a black box
great so now we have that as our
algebraic input let us show that the
norm graph is indeed ast3
in such not so hard once you assume that
they're up there because okay so let's
show norm ask well if you have so okay
what does it mean to have a K as T it
means that if you have distinct vertices
which then correspond to elements s
elements y1 through y of this field then
the common neighbors of these elements
correspond to solutions of this system
of equations where I set all of these
values to be 1 but I can write out
exactly what these guys are because I
have this form that representation
therefore the norm map so I can write it
out and now remember this fact that you
know when you are in characteristic P X
plus y raise to power P it's the same as
X to the P plus white P in
characteristic peep so I can expand the
remaining parentheses like that the
first line 2 equal to 1 and so on each
of the lines has to equal to 1
how many solutions in X does the system
of equation half or so if I even if I
treat each of X an expert opinion and so
on as separate variables that theorem up
there tells me that there are at most s
factorial solutions in X satisfies all
the hypotheses of that theorem up there
therefore the graph is K s sub s
factorial plus 1/3 you do not have as
more than s plus 1 different values of X
satisfying this system of equations and
that's the proof that the storm graph is
K s T free yes question so can you
repeat the question why Cannot the
questions why Cannot the powers of the
piece be the same so you're asking down
the second column let's say why are all
these wives different right because
there you're working inside a field and
raising to the P in in this field is a
bijection so think about the water of
the cyclic group it is co-prime to P
great question anything else ok so this
gives you a construction that is su KS t
3 for T bigger than S Plus expect s
factorial now let me show you how to
improve this construction to do a little
bit better to get s minus 1 factorial
and the idea is to take a variant of
this norm graph which we'll call the
projective norm graph
and the projective norm graph will
define it for s at least three is rather
similar but there's a twist I have as
the vertex set not just the field
extension okay so now I feel the
extension but one level less and I take
a second coordinate which consists of
non zero elements from FP the edges are
formed by putting an edge between these
two elements if and only if the norm
after the sum of the first coordinate
equals to the product of the second
coordinate so now you can run through a
similar calculation that helps you the
number of edges so first of all the
number of vertices is P to the S minus 1
times P minus 1 so basically the same as
P to the yes and additionally every
vertex has degree exactly P raise to s
minus 1 minus 1 and the reason is that
if I tell you the values of X little X
and big Y which cannot equal minus X or
else you will never form an edge then
they together uniquely determine little
Y so for every value of big X and little
X I just need to run through all the
values of Big Y other than minus X
like so the number of edges then equals
to 1/2 times the number of vertices
times the degree of every vertex which
as before is the claimed asymptote and
the remaining thing to show is that this
projective norm graph is KST free so
it's K sub s comma s minus 1 factorial
plus 1 3 ok it's a similar calculation
as the one before but we need to take
into account the small variant in the
construction so suppose we fix as
vertices labeled by this big way little
wise and now we need to solve for
uppercase X lower case X in this system
of equations
so asking how many different pairs big x
lu lu x can appear as a solution to this
system of equations well first of all if
some pairs of the first coordinates big
I is equal to big J then if you have a
solution then that forces look at Y to
be the same as little J and so the Y's
wouldn't have been distinct to begin
with so this is not possible
so all the big y's are distinct well now
let's divide these equations by the
final equation and we get that
the ISEE equation becomes like that
which you can rewrite by dividing by the
coordinate of the norm of Big Y I - pick
Y s right this is non zero because we
just show that all the big why I start
distinct if you divide by this norm here
and rearranged appropriately we find
that the equations become like this
so after doing some rearranging so this
is the equation the set of equations
that we get and you see that if you use
new variables X Prime do a substitution
there's being X Prime then it has
basically the same form as the one that
we just saw with a different set of
constants and in particular from what we
just saw we see that you cannot have
more than s minus 1 factorial solutions
in X now there s minus 1 equations and
the field extension working in the S
minus 1 field extension so we saved an
equation by using this projective
ization and and that's it so this shows
you the claim of constructing a KST 3
graph for T bigger than s minus 1
factorial which has the desired number
of edges yes question ok so the question
is why do we have so why do I say this
part it's ok so I'm skipping a sentence
I'm saying if there is a solution to
this system of equations X but if these
vertices have a common neighbor then if
you have some X satisfying this system
of equations than having two different
big Y's being the same forces you to
have the two small otherwise being the
same right and then the Y's wouldn't
have been distinct ok so for them to
have some common neighbors you better
have this big Y's being distinct any
more questions
great so as I mentioned if it's an open
problem to determine whether one is the
extremal number for K 4 4 k 4 5 k 4 6
and you may ask well we have this nice
construction it may be somewhat
mysterious
because of that theorem there but it's
explicit and you can write this graph
down and gasps it's this graph K for six
free right so do we gain one extra
number for free maybe because we didn't
analyze things properly and it turns out
that's not the case so there was a very
recent paper just released last month
showing that this graph here for s
equals to four actually does contain
some k4 sixes so if you want to prove a
corresponding lower bound for K for six
you better come up with a different
construction and that's I think an
interesting direction to explore any
questions yes right the question is do
we know any similar results about the
scale does this graph contain KS T's for
other values of s and T less than the
claim threshold it is unclear so the
paper that was uploaded its it doesn't
address the issue of s bigger than four
yeah all right so question is why F P to
the power of s so let's go back to the
norm graph construction so where do we
use F P to the power of s well certainly
we needed it to have the right edge
count so that comes up in the edge count
and also in the norm expression you have
the correct number of factors so I
encourage you to try for if you use a
smaller or bigger value of s you either
don't get something which is scarcely
free or you have the wrong number of
edges any more questions
so later I will show you a different
construction of KST three graphs again
forty large compared to s that will not
do as well as though as this one but it
is a genuinely different construction
and it uses the idea of randomized
algebraic construction which is
something that actually was only
developed a few years ago it's a very
recent development and it's quite nice
so it combines some of the things we
talked about with constructing using
random graphs to construct H three
graphs on one hand and on the other hand
some of the algebraic ideas in
particular we're now going to use that
theorem up there
but we'll use some other algebraic
geometry fact ok so let's take a quick
break so what I want to discuss now is a
relatively new idea called a randomized
algebraic construction which combines
some ideas from both the randomized
construction and also the algebraic
construction that we just saw so this
idea is due to a porous book just a few
years ago and the goal is to give an
alternative construction of a KST free
graph with lots of edges provided that I
guess before he is much larger compared
to s ok so this bound here will not be
as good as the one that we just saw and
I won't even tell you what it is but
it's some constant right so for every s
there is some T such that this
construction works
all right as before we working inside
some some finite field geometry so let's
start with Q a prime power you can think
of prime if you like it doesn't make so
much difference so we're working inside
a finite field and let's assume s is
fixed and at least for let me write down
some parameters to worry about them for
now just think of them as sufficiently
large constants so T is this quantity
here so we'll come back to it later when
it comes up okay
so what's the idea when we looked at the
random nice construction we took a
random graph we took an erdos-renyi
random graph every edge appeared
independently and saw that it has lots
of edges if you choose P properly and
not so many copies of H so you can
remove all the copies of H to get a
graph with lots of edges that is h3 what
we're going to do now is instead of
taking the edges randomly we're going to
take a random polynomial f will be a
random polynomial chosen uniformly among
all polynomials worth so I wrote
uppercase Y an uppercase abrogates x and
y actually x and y they're not single
various they are so each of them is a
vector
of s variables okay so in other words X
1 to X s are the variables in the
polynomial and then y1 through wires
so it's a 2's variable polynomial so
among all polynomials with degree at
most P deepen the number up here in each
of x and y sets of variables look at the
s X variables each monomial has their
their exponents sum to a most d and
likewise with each monomial for the Y
variables okay so this is this is the
random object it's a random polynomial
in 2's variables and the degree is
bounded so you only have finite number
of possibilities and I choose one of
them uniformly at random and now what's
my graph we're going to construct a
bipartite graph G the bipartite nurses
it's not so crucial but I will make our
life somewhat easier and the vertices of
the bipartite graph so it has two vertex
parts which I will label left and right
Ln R and they are both the estimation
'el vector space over F cube and we'll
put an edge between two vertices if and
only if that polynomial up there F
evaluates to 0 on these values that's
the graph so I give you a random
polynomial F and then you putting edges
according to when f vanishes so f if you
knew the bipartite graph as a subset of
FQ today s cross F 2 DVS and this is the
0
that the edge said is the zero set okay
just like in random graphs with the
construction with random grass well need
to show a couple of things one is that
has lots of edges which would not be
hard to show and second that it will
have typically a small number of copies
of KST and that will have some
ingredients which are similar to the
random graphs case we saw before but it
will have some new ideas coming from
algebraic geometry first let's show that
this graph has lots of edges and that's
a simple calculation because for every
pair of points of vertices I claim that
the probability so here F is the random
object the probability that F evaluates
to 0 on this pair is exactly Q so
exactly 1 over Q 1 over the size of the
field so this is not too hard and the
reason is that the distribution of F is
identically so identical to if you add
an extra random constant on F
chosen uniformly at random so I take a
random polynomial I shifted by random
constant it's still a uniformly random
polynomial according to that
distribution but now you see that this
whatever F evaluated to if I shift by a
random constant you will end up with a
uniform distribution so it tells you
that that guy up there yes
uniform distribution on every fixed
point u comma V so in particular it hits
zero with probability exactly 1 over Q
and as a result the number of edges of G
in the expectation is exactly N squared
over Q where n is the number of vertices
so n is not the number of vertices but
the size of each vertex part namely see
that it gives you the right number of
edges n to the 2 minus 1 over s so we
have the right number of edges and now
we want to show that this graph here
typically does not have too many copies
of K STS it might have some copies of KS
t somehow that is unavoidable
just as in random case you do have some
copies of KS T's but if there are not
too many copies I can remove them and
obtain a KS d3 graph ok so what is the
intuition how does it compare to the
case when you have genuine erdos-renyi
random graph well what is the expected
number of common neighbors so if I give
you so if you fix some you
with I say on the left side with exactly
as vertices I want to understand how
many common neighbors that's you have
because the common neighbors if he has
too many common neighbors then that's a
KST it is not hard too hard to calculate
the expectation of this quantity both in
the random graph case as well as in this
case and you can calculate you know if
you pretend every edge occurs
independently the expected number of
common neighbors is exactly n to the Q
to the minus s which is exactly 1 and
you know that for a binomial
distribution with expectation 1 and a
large number of variables the
distribution is approximately per Sonia
but that's in the case winners
independently distributed well just the
case in the case of GMP but it turns out
for the algebraic setting we're doing
here
things don't behave independently it's
not that you're doing coin flops for
every eight possible edge we're doing
some randomized algebraic construction
and for algebraic geometry reasons you
will see that the distribution is very
much not like poor Sonia it will turn
out that either peconics
the number of common neighbors is
bounded or it is very large and that
means that we can show using some Markov
inequality that the probability that it
is very large is quite small so
typically it will not have many common
neighbors and that's the intuition and
so let's work out this intuition any
questions so far
alright so how do we do this calculation
so first let's start with something
that's actually fairly elementary so
suppose you have some parameters R and s
so I think of R and s let's okay so some
parameters R and s and think of them as
constants have some restrictions but
don't worry too much about them suppose
I have two bounded subset of of the
final field where u has size s and V has
size R then the claim is that the
probability that F vanishes on the
Cartesian product of U and V
okay so what do you expect it to be so I
have s our elements and I want F this
random polynomial to vanish on the
entire product or if s value behaved
independently for every point you should
expect that the probability is exactly Q
to the power minus SR and it turns out
that is the case so this is true this is
an exact statement okay so why is this
true so this is in sometimes a
generalization of this claim over here
and it's you have to do a little bit
more work but it's not too difficult
so let's first consider this lemma in a
somewhat simpler case where all the
first coordinates of X are distinct of
you are distinct and all the first
coordinates of V are distinct suppose U
and V have that form so I'll write down
the list of points for you and first
coordinates are all distinct what I want
to do is to give you a random shift to
do a uniform random shift and I will
shifted by a polynomial G which is a
bivariate polynomial so these are not
vectors they are just single variables
and I look at all possible sum of
monomials where the degree in I is less
than s and the degree in J is less than
this
ace are chosen uniformly independently
at random from the ground field FQ and
as before we see that F and F plus G had
the same distribution the same
probability distribution and so only
remains to show that is whatever F comes
out to be if I talk on this randomness
extra random G it creates a uniform
distribution on the values on the entire
you cross me but actually see I have s
our choices exactly for these
coefficients and I have s our values
that I'm trying to control so really
it's a counting problem and it all it
suffices to show at my ejection namely
that for every possible vector of values
there exists a choice of coefficients
that's above such that G evaluates to
the prescribed values with the given
coefficients
[Applause]
and then uniformity would follow just
because you have the exact if you just
do accounting and the one-dimensional
version of this claim okay so let's
think about what that is right so if I
have say three points on the line and a
degree two polynomial what I'm saying is
that if you give me the values you want
on these three points I can produce for
you a unique polynomial that valuates to
the prescribed values on these three
points and that you should all know as
Lagrange interpolation so it tells you
exactly how to do that and that works
for many reasons one of them is that the
vendôme on determinant is invertible
here we have multi variables so let's do
Lagrange interpolation twice once for
each variable so we'll apply the
interpolation twice so the first time
we'll see that for all values of u there
exists a single barrier polynomial in
the Y variable
with degree at most R minus one that
evaluates to the correct values wrong
piece on the person on the fixed not on
you
so do it for one variable at a time so
fix you will know you do Lagrange
interpolation on the Y variable and now
once we have those things they're
viewing the G that we want to find as a
polynomial whose coefficients are
polynomials in the X variables but
itself is a polynomial in the Y variable
we find that again using Lagrange
interpolation there exists these values
for these coefficients here such that
each coefficient off if you plug in the
first entry to little you agrees with
the coefficients of the G that we just
found and that should be the case for
every before you okay so once you find
these polynomials and now you have a
bonafide polynomial in G and that's the
claim above so using Lagrange
interpolation twice once for each
variable okay so this is you're confused
just think about it this is there's
nothing deep here so that finishes the
claim in the case when you when the
first coordinates all distinct right so
we use that fact crucially in doing this
Lagrange interpolation now for general
und where we don't have this assumption
of having distinct first coordinates
well let's make them to have distinct
first coordinates by considering a
random linear transformation also using
a probabilistic method
so so randomly so we suffice us to find
invertible linear maps ki and s this
vector space such that tu and SP have
the above properties so let me show you
how to do it for you so I need to find
you a invertible linear transformation T
it's just the first coordinate that
matters so it suffices to find just a
linear map corresponding to the first
coordinate that is injective you
whatever linear map you have even if
it's zero that's fine I can extend it to
the remaining coordinates if it's zero
then it's not going to be injective on
you okay well let's find this map
randomly so pick T uniform random among
all linear maps and I want to understand
what is the probability of collision bad
event if two elements of you end up
getting mapped to the same point well
that's not too hard so for every
distinct pair of points in fq to the S
the probability that
so the probability that they collide
think about why this is true it's
exactly 1 over s 1 over Q if X and X
prime they differ in at least one
coordinate then even just along that
coordinate I can make them distinct so
this is the case for every pair
so now by Union bound the probability
that t1 is injective on U is at least 1
minus the size of you choose 2 times 1
over Q and that's why we chose Q to be
large enough so Q is at least R squared
x squared so this number here is
positive so such a key exists and so we
can transform this U and V two
configurations where the first
coordinates are all distinct and then
run the argument as before
ok great
so what we've shown so far is that if
you look at this K as our structures
they appear what probability exactly
what term with expectation exactly what
you might expect as an independent
random case but what we really don't
want to understand is the distribution
of the number of common neighbors and in
particular we want to upper bound the
probability that there are too many
common neighbors we want to understand
some kind of tail probabilities and to
do that one way to do tail probabilities
is to consider moments yes question
so can you repeat the question question
how do I have the Equality right before
the lemma ah
so right there I'm actually saying for
the eldest rainy random graphs case
that's the that's the case earliest when
a random graph each edge you have the
same edge probability is 1 over Q and an
that's the number of common neighbors
you will expect so that's a heuristic
for the erdos-renyi random graph case ok
so now let's try to understand the
distribution of the number of common
neighbors so let's fix a you subset of F
P to the S with exactly s elements and I
want to understand how many common
neighbors it has so let's consider the
number of common neighbors of you and
the death moment of this random variable
okay so this is a common way to do upper
tail bounds and one way to analyze such
moments is to decompose this count as a
sum of indicator random variables so let
me write RB to be the quantity which is
1 if f you B is 0 for all before you and
big you in other words it's a common
neighbor it's 1 if B is a common
neighbor for you and 0 otherwise
so then the number of common neighbors
would simply be the sum of this
indicator as V ranges over the entire
vertex set and I can expand this sum and
all of these are standard things to do
when you're trying to calculate moments
okay so I can bring this expectation
inside and try to understand what is the
expectation of the object inside well if
all the B's are distinct then this is
simply the expected number of K as DS
right but these might not be this thing
so we need to be a little bit careful
but that's not too hard to handle
so let me write M sub r to be the number
of surjective functions from the element
set when our element set and m to be the
sum of these M sub ours for our up to
deep then let's consider how many
distinct V values are there if there are
distinct V values then they take on that
many possible values and M are for the
number of surjections and for each
possible or the exact number for the
exact value of this expectation is Q to
the minus RS and that's exactly what we
showed all right so this comes from
lemma just now
but we chose I mean look this is a
binomial coefficient and you have this
number here so they multiply to a most
one so we have this number this quantity
which I think of as a constant right so
this is a constant so the teeth moment
is bounded and okay and one way to get
tell pounds once you have the moments is
that we can use Markov inequality tell
us had a number of common neighbors of
you the probability that you has too
many common neighbors more than lambda
common neighbors I can rewrite this
inequality here by raising both sides to
the power D and then using Markov
inequality take expectation divide all
of these are standard techniques for
upper tail estimation you want to
understand the upper tail of some random
variable understand the X understand its
moments and you smart off on its moments
but now we know what we have some bound
for the death moment right which is M as
we just showed so there's this bound
here so far you can run the same
argument in the random graphs case and
you wouldn't really do much different I
mean everything is more or less the same
what I've said so far although we had to
do a special calculation algebraically
that didn't really make sense I mean
that you have to show some kind of near
independence question
hmm thank you thank you but now is where
the algebra comes in algebraic geometry
nature of this argument comes in it
turns out that this quantity here
previously we said at least
heuristically in the random grass case
it behaves like a Quapaw song random
variable so it's fairly uniform in a
Poisson sense it turns out because of
the algebraic nature of the construction
this random variable behaves nothing
like a puzzle so it turns out this
highly constrained due to reasons in
algebraic geometry and I'll tell you
exactly why so that the number of common
neighbors is either very small or very
large and here is the claim that for
every s and D there exists some C such
that if I have a bunch of polynomials FQ
to the S of degree all at most D then if
you look at a number of zeros common
zeros of the f
how many common zeros can have it turns
out I cannot just be some arbitrary
number so this set has size either
bounded and most C or it is at least Q
minus something very small and I'll
explain just a little bit why this is
the case although I will now give a
proof so either
somehow you are working in a zero
dimensional case or if this algebraic
variety that comes with it has positive
dimension then you should have a lot
more points
and the reason for this dichotomy is has
to do with how many points are there on
an algebraic variety over a finite field
so I will not give a proof although if
you look at the course website or link
to a reference that does have a proof
but I will tell you what the key
algebraic geometric input yes - to that
claim up there and this is a important
famous theorem called the Lange way
bound
ok so the line they bound tells you that
if you have an algebraic variety V and
for now it is important in order to say
this property to work in the algebraic
culture so that's the algebraic closure
it's the smallest field extension where
I can solve all polynomial equations
then the variety cut out by a set of
polynomials okay so so V is this variety
so if it has irreducible cannot be with
him
I say union of finite number of smaller
varieties you reduce ball over FQ bar
and all of these polynomials have the
Greek bounded then the question is if I
take these polynomials and I look at how
many fu points does it have right so in
other words if now I leave the field I
come back down to earth to the base
field and ask what's the number of
solutions in
where the coordinates are in FQ okay so
how many points do you expect well the
simplest example of an algebraic variety
is that of a subspace if you have a B
dimensional sub space over F Q you have
Q to the D points exactly so you expect
something like Q raised to the dimension
of the variety now the dimension is
actually somewhat subtle concept
I won't define but you know there are
many definitions in algebraic geometry
okay it turns out it's not always
exactly as nice as in the case of linear
subspaces but the line they bound tells
us that it's not too far off you have a
deviation that is at most on the water
of Q 1 over root Q where there are some
hidden constants depending on the
description off you are variety in terms
of the degrees of the polynomials that
dimension and the number of polynomials
but the point is that the number of
points on this variety is basically
should be around the same as the model
case namely that of a subspace and and
that brings us some intuition to why
this lemma is true right so you have
those polynomials up there so there are
some subtle points one needs to verify
about your disability but the punchline
is that either you are in the zero
dimensional case in which case you have
something like by Zeus theorem that
tells you that the number of solutions
is bounded or you are in the positive
dimensional case in which case the leg
may term tells you you must have lots of
solutions and there's no middle ground
and now we're ready to finish off Bohr's
books construction
so we see that applying this lemma up
there where this what should be my
polynomial speed I'm going to use my
polynomials F sub u Y to be I have a
random polynomial up there so I'm trying
to find common neighbors I'm trying to
find common solutions so so these are my
polynomial says u ranges over thank you
so for Q large enough we find that the
number of common neighbors of U the
probability that is bigger than C where
C is supplied by that lemma is equal to
the probability that the number of
common neighbors of U exceeds say Q over
2 or Q over tours some this quality
around it smaller than that quantity up
there so if as more than C solutions
that automatically has lots of solutions
and now we can apply the markov
inequality up there the tail bound on
the moments to deduce that this
probability is that most M divided by Q
over 2 raised to the power D and the
more of it is that we should have a very
small number I mean and this should
occur with very small probability so
let's call you being a subset of the bad
if you pass our elements us contained
entirely on the left side or the right
side of the original by partition and
most importantly you
a lot maybe more than C common neighbors
in Jeep how many paths s do we expect
basically a very small number so the
number of paths sets values is upper
bounded by for each choice of s elements
the probability that something is bad is
this quantity up here which no we chose
T to be a large enough constant
depending on s if you look at the choice
of be up there see that this quantity
here is quite a bit smaller than the
number of vertices and now the last step
is the same as our randomized
construction using erdos-renyi random
graphs where we remove it's almost the
same but now we remove one vertex from
every bad set
and we get some graph G Prime and we
just need to check that G Prime has lots
of edges we now got rid of all the bad
sets so G prime is now K sub s C plus 1
3 we got rid of all possibilities for s
points having more than C common
neighbors now we just need to check that
G prime has lots of edges or the
expected number of edges in G prime is
at least D X what we removed one vertex
for every bad you and each path you
carry sweater at most n edges because
there are only n edges on each side of
the by partition and the number of edges
of G has expectation exactly N squared
over Q and the number of paths use we
saw up there is not very large so in
particular this quantity the second term
is dominated by the first term and so we
obtain the claimed number of edges
also the graph has and most 2n vertices
may have gotten some gotten rid of Sam
but actually fewer vertices the better
so most 2n vertices and it is K sub s so
it's KST 340 large enough so this gives
you another construction of KS t 3
graphs and so today we saw two different
constructions of KS t free graphs for
constants s and people in both cases T
is substantially larger than s but the
most important thing is that they both
match the Kaveri shows Turin bound
actually gives you some evidence that
maybe the Kaveri shows torrent
conjecture the the theorem is tight up
to a most a constant factor although
that is a major open problem and it
remains very difficult it seems open
problem but one that is central
importance in extremo graph theory to
try to come up perhaps with other
constructions that can do better maybe
they will have some algebraic input but
maybe they will have some input from
other ideas we do not know question
questions is Q defined so we just like
in the proofs of polarity graphs and
whatnot
so you have some n you round it down to
the nearest prime powers as a constant
so n is basically Q to the s so take
large and round it down to the nearest
prime power Q could be a prime for
instance it could be a prime could be a
prime power think Q to be a prime so I'm
saying for every Q there is a
construction and for every end you can
take round down to the nearest Q to the
s and then run this construction
any more questions
great so next time I will begin by
telling you a few more things about you
know why people really like this
construction and some conjectures that
were solved using this idea and some
constructions I still remain open along
the same lines and we'll also go beyond
KST right so other bipartite graphs and
show you how to do upper bounds for
those bipartite graphs